after the loss to denver in november
you called out some teammates and even
your gm said hey ben's earned the right
to call out teammates pulling the ball
back and throwing over top of his head
to antonio
was supposed to be running a real flat
down the line kind of route what did you
learn from that whole experience of
calling out a b in particular yeah i i i
wish i would have done it um you know
because obviously we saw what happened
and obviously it ruined a friendship
they just got caught up in the emotion
to hear the battle but the other person
i i
challenged
that game was james washington and i
know people made a big deal about that
but james washington texted me
called me and talked to me in person and
thanking me for that and so the outside
world was killing me for it he thanked
me and that's all that really mattered
why do you think abe was not able to
handle it the same way you ought to ask
him i'm not sure
ben roethlisberger with michelle tafoya
an interview that aired sunday night as
part of the steelers titans preseason
game chris this one's easy for me and i
i don't know maybe ben roethlisberger is
just playing a little dumb on this
james washington is the rookie james
washington is the guy who's sucking up
right to the boss to the guy who
distributes the football he's going to
say thank you sir may i have another
yeah you're right abs the established
veteran who's been dealing with this
crap for eight years in his mind that's
his way of thinking of it i'm i'm done
i've had enough right that's the
difference yes and and and to take what
is packaged as an apology
and to spin it into well i did the same
thing with this guy and he thanked me
for it are you really apologizing or are
you trying to paint the guy who was
upset with what you said as being
unreasonable for being upset yeah i
don't know what he was trying to
accomplish with the last part of that
comment you're right there he was kind
of trying to justify it just a little
bit to a degree without really diving
into it but i mean you said it it was
wrong he knows it was wrong and
especially to somebody it was wrong to
do to anybody let alone doing it to
antonio brown who's going to be a first
ballot hall of famer and been one of the
best players in the nfl for the last two
years so that's where it was wrong and
really more than anything it just didn't
seem like ben wanted to take the
accountability himself i don't give a
damn how flat antonio brown had to go on
that the only the only way he was gonna
get underneath shelby harris there who
intercepted the ball was to be behind
the line of scrimmage so he wasn't
supposed to go that flat okay i mean
really or he's gonna have to run into
the offensive lineman so big ben again
uh hey he's i'm sure he's had to deal
with well you know some some polarizing
figures some some tough personalities
there in pittsburgh and he messed up
here for sure and he is taking
accountability for it but yet i know
he's trying to kind of smooth it over
there with a little bit he said all
together
it's conditional accountability aimed at
making the person who's upset with him
seem like they're in the wrong for being
upset they should be thankful that the
quarterback is trying to help them in
this way and there's something else he
threw out there he mentioned the phrase
heat of the battle it was two days later
it was cold blooded he was talking on
the telephone to a radio station this
isn't oh cameras spot ben roethlisberger
chewing out antonio brown on the
sidelines during the game no this is two
days after the fact where he can say
whatever he wants to say and he chooses
to blame antonio brown for not running
the right route this is not heat of the
battle this is calculated after the fact
and i can see why antonio brown was
upset and i don't understand how ben
rothersberger would try to justify it by
saying oh the new kid
uh who lets me run all over him right
was actually thankful that i called him
out yeah what else is he gonna say and
let me tell you if that james washington
becomes a star
a few years from now he's not going to
be thanking ben roethlisberger if he
gets called out no he's not i mean you
know and again i'll say this for big ben
though okay you know the heat of the
battle is sometimes does still go to the
next day or two days later because
you're still just torn up inside when
you lose a football game like that and
that was one of the most brutal losses
of the season for the pittsburgh
steelers they kind of dominated that
football game against the denver broncos
and fumbled on the one inch line he
threw that interception james connor was
running down the field on another
scoring drive and a wide open play he
fumbled i mean they blew it and yeah he
didn't want to take the accountability
but now we got to talk about the antonio
brown tweet too i mean shut up already
okay well i mean he got asked a question
he's got to answer the damn question
okay first off you know and you know the
par the first part of this and i've said
this before never you know just how to
get my ends antonio brown was going to
make an issue no matter what at the end
of last year it didn't matter if ben
roethlisberger was the best person on
earth last year during the season he
wanted out because he wanted more money
that's all there is to it he was afraid
juju was going to get his money next
contract he wanted out and that's
everything i've been told from just
about everybody in football
antonio brown by the way has since
deleted that yeah that tweet was out
there and
i have a feeling these issues will
continue to come up in the coming days
weeks and months
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports